[This tape was duplicated from a 16mm film
by Colorlab for the National Library of Medicine.
August 2003.
NLM call number HF 1601]
[Seal of U.S. Public Health Service 1798]
[Tropical Disease Investigations In Africa]
[By Thomas A. Burch, M.D.]
[Laboratory of Tropical Diseases.
National Institute of Allergy and Infectious
Diseases.
Department of Health Education and Welfare.]
[With the Cooperation of the Health Departments
of Liberia.
Belgian Congo.
Mozambique.
Kenya.]
[And the Liberian Institute of the American
Foundation for Tropical Medicine]
Even today, in the age of the hydrogen bomb
and supersonic flight, much of Africa remains
wild and primeval.
In many parts of the continent, wild animals
such as the elephant, giraffe, hippopotamus,
and others still abound.
Over large areas, man still lives a primitive
existence in much the same way as did his
forebears.
Civilization has left little imprint upon
him and he still carries on his daily occupation
in accordance with his ancient customs.
In vast areas in Africa there are countless
persons suffering from many strange and exotic
diseases, some of which are found nowhere
else in the world.
Some of these diseases are swift killers,
while others leave their victims permanently
incapacitated until death finally intervenes.
These diseases greatly interfere with the
economic development of the tropical countries
and hamper the exportation of enormous reservoirs
of material resources so much needed by the
free world.
Furthermore, there's a constant threat of
the spread beyond the tropics by means of
today's rapid transportation systems.
Research in the field of tropical medicine
is of more than academic or altruistic concern
to the people of the United States, because
our own economy is involved.
60 percent of our imports come from the tropical
countries, including many of the strategic
materials which we lack.
Before one can hope to control or eliminate
these various diseases, it is necessary to
study them in the areas in which they are
prevalent.
To do this, scientists must make their way
into the heart of the endemic areas by whatever
means are available.
Shown here is a National Institutes of Health
research team working as a part of the Point
Four program, leaving for a field survey in
the Liberian hinterland.
Field investigations are especially important
in arriving at methods for the prevention
and control of tropical diseases.
Tropical medicine is not a static science
and the tropics cover vast areas of the globe.
Methods employed to combat a particular disease
in one part of the tropics may not be equally
applicable elsewhere.
All aspects of tropical medicine, however,
cannot be studied in the field but must be
investigated at special research centers.
Not only in the tropics, but also in the more
advanced areas where specialized equipment
and qualified personnel are more readily available.
This film will show how aspects of some of
the more important tropical diseases of Africa,
with special reference to conditions in Liberia,
West Africa.
Together with some of the research work being
done not only in that area, but also at the
National Institutes of Health of the United
States Public Health Service.
Malaria is an acute, recurring, febrile disease
caused by protozoan parasites of the genus
plasmodium which are transmitted by an integral
part of their life cycle in certain Anopheline
mosquitoes.
This disease is one of the main obstacles
to successful settlement in many warm countries.
The part it plays in general world morbidity
and mortality is hard to judge, but it is
thought to be responsible for more illness
and death per year than any other transmissable
disease.
The prevalence of malaria parasites in a population
group can best be ascertained by means of
microscopic examination of thick blood smears.
While the parasites are more abundant in the
blood of infants and children before the development
of immunity, it is not uncommon in hyper-endemic
areas to demonstrate them in 80 to 90 percent
of adults examined.
Thick blood smears are used primarily in surveys
and for case bindings because of high concentration
of parasites provided by this technique.
Thin blood smears are more suitable when exact
species determination is required or when
morphological studies are desired.
In order to gain a complete picture of malaria
in any region, it is necessary to study the
mosquitoes that transmit it.
Larvae and pupae of Anopheline mosquitoes
are sought in the field in order to locate
their breeding areas and to study the conditions
under which they multiply.
Adult mosquitoes can be captured in traps
placed over windows of huts.
The study of these mosquitoes will show, among
other things, which species are the most important
vectors in a given locality.
This is done by demonstrating sporozoites,
the infective stage of the malaria parasite,
in the salivary glands of the mosquito.
These glands are easily dissected from the
mosquito and when gently crushed under the
cover slip, the sporozoites are expelled and
can be readily seen under the microscope.
Only a small portion of the mosquitoes captured
are found infected.
But in view of the vast numbers which feed
on unprotected individuals in the tropics,
even a small percentage of infected mosquitoes
is sufficient to maintain a high incidence
of infection in the population.
The clinical diagnosis of malaria is frequently
difficult.
It may be confused with many diseases, both
cosmopolitian and tropical.
This is inevitable in view of the pathology
which consists mainly of mechanical interference
with the vascular supply of many organs of
the body.
Among the tropical diseases with which it
may be confused are telehezar (??), amoebic
liver abscess, relapsing fever, and yellow
fever.
Among the cosmopolitian diseases, it may simulate
typhoid fever, tuberculosis, brucellosis,
influenza, myelitis, and other septic conditions
as well as certain diseases of the central
nervous system.
Great strides have been made in recent years
in developing new drugs for the suppression
and treatment of malaria by testing thousands
of compounds against the malarias of lower
animals, such as chicks.
The drug being tested here is administered
orally to the infected chick.
Blood smears are prepared before and at intervals
after treatment.
The anti-malarial effect of the compound is
then determined by the presence or absence
of the malaria parasite.
An essential part of all research concerns
the publication of the results.
Shown here is a monograph in which data on
nearly four thousand compounds are analyzed
to show the relationship between chemical
structure and anti-malarial activity.
The final evaluation of any anti-malarial
drug must of course be made against human
malaria in endemic areas.
[Onchocerciasis] Onchocerciasis is a form
of filariasis transmitted by gnats of the
genus Simulium.
The adult worms live in subcutaneous nodules,
while the larvae, or microfilari, migrate
within the layers of the skin.
These microfilari frequently penetrate into
the structures of the eye so that a variable
proportion of the population in the endemic
area suffers from partial or complete blindness.
Blindness due to this disease usually affects
less than 1 percent of the population.
However, in scattered focii, the incidence
may be extremely high.
The subcutaneous nodules, which contain the
coiled up adult worms, are the most characteristic
lesions of onchocerciasis.
Ocular changes usually occur only after long
and repeated exposure.
These changes bear no relation to the anatomic
location of the nodules but rather are associated
with the development of sensitivity to antigenic
substances produced by the parasite or its
product.
The most widely distributed vector of onchocerciasis
in Africa is the gnat Simulium damnosum, which
breeds in cataracts and waterfalls of rapidly
flowing streams where the larvae and pupae
may be found attached to submerged stones
and vegetation.
The other principle vector is Simulium [medei],
which is found primarily in East Africa and
parts of the Congo.
It was only after years of diligent search
that the larvae and pupae of this fly were
found to live only on the carapace and legs
of a freshwater crab, potamon niloticus.
The discovery of the oscology of the larval
and pupal stages of this gnat has greatly
simplified the control and eradication of
onchocerciasis in the areas in which Simulium
[medei] is the sole vector.
The Simulia are daytime feeders which have
a painless bite and are not easily disturbed
after they have started feeding.
The incidence of infection in these flies
is determined by searching for developing
stages of the worm onchocerca in nets captured
while feeding on natives serving as human
bait.
The ingested larvae, or microfilari, leave
the stomach of the fly and penetrate the thoracic
muscles where they grow into the so-called
'sausage stage'.
After six days or more of development, the
elongated infective larvae travel to the labium
of the fly.
When the insect bites another person, the
larvae escape and penetrate into the skin.
The microfilari live in the dermis of the
skin and can be demonstrated easily in skin
biopsies which consist of thin slices of skin
placed in drops of normal saline.
This method is satisfactory only where onchocerca
is the only filarid encountered, since microfilari,
which are characteristically found in the
blood, occasionally occur in skin biopsies.
All species of microfilari can be readily
demonstrated and identified in scarification
smears which are prepared by making several
superficial incisions in the skin with a scalpel
and squeezing out the blood and tissue juices.
This material can be examined fresh for motile
micro filari, but must be examined as a thick
blood smear stained with hematoxylin to determine
the species.
Wuchereria bancrofti microfilari have a sheath
and the nuclei extends farther forward than
do those of the onchocerca volvulus which
have a somewhat bulbous head and no sheath.
[Trypanosomiasis]
Trypanosomiasis is an acute and chronic disease
produced by protozoan parasites of the genus
Trypanosoma.
American trypanosomiasis, or Chagas disease,
is caused by trypanosoma cruzi which is transmitted
by bugs of the genus Tryatoma.
[Trypanosoma Cruzi]
African trypanosomiasis, or sleeping sickness,
is caused by trypanosoma gambiense in the
western and equatorial parts of Africa and
trypanosoma rhodesiense in the eastern part
of the continent.
[Trypanosoma Cruzi.
Tryapanosoma Gambiense.
Trypanosoma Rhodesiense]
Both are transmitted by various species of
glossina or tsetse flies.
It is said that the economic future of equatorial
Africa depends largely upon the issue of the
struggle of science against the scourge of
trypanosom diseases which affect both man
and domestic animals.
The sleeping or somnolent stage of gambien
trypanosomiasis begins with apathy associated
with tremors, shuffling gait, and incoordination
from which it proceeds to true coma and eventually
death.
The latter is usually due to malnutrition
or intercurrent infection.
When the trypanosomes are ingested by the
tsetse fly, they undergo a cyclical development
in the digestive tract.
After 18-34 days, infective trypanosomes leave
the salivary ducts and enter the bite wound
at the next feeding.
Glossina palpalis, the tsetse fly which transmits
Gambian sleeping sickness, frequents the dense
undergrowth bordering water courses.
The pregnant female produces a single, large,
fully developed larvae at intervals of about
ten days.
The larva burrows into the ground to a depth
of about two inches and immediately pupates.
The pupa hatches into an adult fly in three
to 12 weeks.
Tsetse flies of the glossina morsitans group
which transmit Rhodesian sleeping sickness
are less dependent upon water and are found
in wooded savanna country that provides moderate
shade.
Cover is more or less essential and suitable
breeding grounds largely determine the location
of the fly belt.
With drugs now available, it is possible to
cure the majority of sleeping sickness patients,
provided they are treated before invasion
of the central nervous system by the parasite.
All individuals in an endemic area are examined
for evidence of the disease, such as enlarged
posterior cervical lymph nodes, which is called
Winterbottom's sign.
And for the presence of the parasite in blood
smears.
Nodule aspiration is useful in diagnosing
the Gambian form of the disease.
A study of the spinal fluid will determine
whether the central nervous system is involved.
An increase in the amount of protein or in
the cell count indicates such involvement.
In which event, the patient must be treated
with one of the more toxic, arsenical compounds
such as tryparsamide or arsabal.
Due to the rather ineffective methods of diagnosing
sleeping sickness, attempts are being made
to develop tests which will detect the disease
in early stages.
Fractions of protein derived from trypanosomes
are purified by various procedures including
dialysis and then concentrated by evaporization
and myopalization.
Drying is completed under vacuum while the
material is still frozen.
The resulting product is then used in various
types of serologic tests.
Information gleaned from basic research on
the physiology and metabolism of the trypanosome
contributes to knowledge of the parasite and
may lead to the development of a drug that
will destroy them regardless of their location
in the human body.
[Comparative Studies on the metabolism of
the culture form and bloodstream form of Trypanosoma
Gambiense]
[Schistosomiasis]
Schistosomiasis, a chronic disease caused
by blood flukes of the genus Schistosoma,
is characterized by inflammatory and proliferative
lesions of the liver, genital urinary, and
lower intestinal tracts.
Several species of schistosomes are capable
of infecting man but only three are important
clinically: Schistosoma mansoni and the more
virulent Schistosoma japonicum primarily involve
the intestinal tract, While Schistosoma hematobium
affects the genital urinary tract.
[Schistosoma mansoni.
Schistosoma japonicum.
Schistosoma hematobium.]
Schistosomiasis is one of the most widespread
and serious of all the diseases produced by
animal parasites.
The disease is estimated to affect 115 million
people in the world and seems to be spreading
into near-eastern Brazil.
Shown here is a district health clinic in
the Liberian hinterland staffed by a U.S.
Public Health Service physician under the
foreign technical assistance program.
Nearly half of the patients attending this
clinic have urinary schistosomiasis.
Symptoms of this infection are caused by small
ulcers in the bladder and consist of hematuria,
burning on urination, and super-pubic or perineal
pain.
The prevalence of schistosomiasis varies considerably
from place to place, even in the same endemic
area, and hence surveys are necessary to evaluate
its local importance.
The ova of schistosoma hematoibum in the urine
are concentrated by centrifugation.
The supernatant is decanted and the sediment
is examined under the microscope for the eggs.
When the schistosome egg reaches fresh water,
a ciliated larva, or miracidium, is free and
must find and penetrate a suitable snail host
in order to continue the life cycle.
Only a few species of snails are capable of
serving as intermediate hosts for the schistosomes.
In the snail, the parasite undergoes a two-phase
process of development ending in four to seven
weeks with the production of tens of thousands
of free swimming, infective forms called cercariae.
When an individual wades or works in infested
waters, the organisms become attached to the
exposed skin and penetrate within a few minutes.
Slow-moving streams clogged with vegetation
and high organic content are particularly
favorable habitats for the snails which transmit
Schistosomiasis.
In such advantageous surroundings, these snails
frequently are found in enormous numbers.
Man himself contributes to their welfare and
to the spread of the disease when he disturbs
natural conditions and constructs new ponds,
alters the course of streams, or introduces
irrigation systems.
Colonies of snails that serve as vectors of
schistosomiasis in many parts of the world
are maintained at the National Institutes
of Health and are utilized in research on
prevention and control of this disease.
The molluscicide effect of numerous compounds
has been determined in the laboratory by mixing
various concentrations of the substance being
tested in small aquaria.
The vector snails are then added to the treated
water and after a stated interval of time,
the snails are removed and the lethal action
of the compound is determined by noting the
proportion of dead and live snails.
Using this or some other techniques, it has
been shown that sodium pentachlorophenate
is an effective molluscicide, and numerous
field tests have been made with this compound.
Shown here is a report on an experiment to
compare the effect of this chemical on different
laboratory strains of the same vector species.
Studies to determine the mechanism of action
of sodium pentaclorophenate have been made
on various species of snails.
Shown here is an experiment in which a suspension
of cells is prepared by convoluting the liver
of a snail followed by differential centrifugation.
Various concentrations of a molluscicide are
added to this suspension and the effect on
the metabolism on the cell is observed.
These studies indicate that the molluscicidal
property of sodium pentachlorophenate is due
at least in part to its ability to inactivate
certain enzyme systems and thus prevent the
cell from utilizing the energy available from
the metabolic breakdown of nutriments.
Comparative studies on the physiology and
metabolism of the same species of vector snails
from different geographical areas, such as
the anaerobic carbon dioxide production experiment
shown here, have demonstrated much differences
in what appear to be identical snails.
This helps to explain why snails in different
areas do not always react similarly to identical
control measures.
The schistosomacidal activity of numerous
drugs has been tested in mice.
These animals have been infected by inserting
their tails into waters containing live cercariae.
After the infection is developed the mice
were treated with the test compound, and after
suitable intervals are autopsied to determined
the schistosomacidal effect of the drug.
Untreated mice, or those treated with ineffective
compounds, have adult worms in their messentaric
and portal veins and evidence of innumerable
eggs in the liver.
Mice treated with effective drugs have few
eggs in the liver and show remains of dead
worms in the liver tissue.
Furthermore, all adult worms have disappeared
from the messentaric and portal veins.
In this experiment, antibiotic complexes of
antimony trichloride were found to be active
orally against Schistosoma mansoni.
But no more active than plain antimony trichloride
or tartar emetic.
It is hoped that eventually an effective and
nontoxic drug will be found to aid in the
control of what the World Health Organization
considers to be one of the world's most important
health problems.
During the past half-century, great strides
have been made in our knowledge of tropical
diseases.
However, only a few of these diseases have
been adequately controlled.
Because of their public health and economic
importance, they must be studied more intensively
both in the laboratory and in the field.
If these maladies can be further checked and
ultimately eradicated, Africa need no longer
be referred to as the dark continent.
Equal benefits will rebound to other parts
of the globe where many of these scourges
also take their toll.
[The End]
[Produced with the assistance of the Photographic
Section, Scientific Reports Branch, Division
Of Research Services, National Institutes
of Health.]